ça arrive de temps en temps que tu es un
câble à 1 dans l'ombre
n'importe quel monde je
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peux vous dire que je vais très bien
alors oui j'ai un peu changé de look le
protocole a plutôt bien marché puisque
dès les deux premières chimio
immunothérapie ma tumeur qui était
grosse comme un kiwi s'est transformé en
une noisette il a repris du poids il va
très bien et on embrasse mais comment il
va justement aujourd'hui où est ce qu'on
a mais en étant honnête au moment où on
publie sa il attend les résultats d'un
scanner d'accord n'est pas encore prêt
sont censés être très rassurant ouais la
taille de sa tumeur un gourou l'objectif
c'est de la faire diminuer au maximum
pour pouvoir opérer juste pas d'accord
et à l'heure où on se parle il est en
tout cas moi je ne suis pas au courant
d'une opération programmée concernant
florent pagny d'accord donc a priori
pour qu'une guérison soit totale on
n'est jamais totalement mais vraiment
envisagé il faudrait plus en passer par
là voilà pour vraiment statut
il ira ta copine kate middleton isonat
met quelques jours après leur
accouchement ses stars n'hésitent pas à
s'afficher votre plat alors forcément ça
énerve vous pensez qu'en fait quand on
fait des enfants c'est comme dans les
films qu'on accouche on revient taille
32 des 34 heureusement certaines
célébrités prône le body positive une
tendance qui consiste à s'accepter tel
que l'on est
alors bébé jeu comme tu fais quelque
chose même si tu es très belle une femme
en moyenne prend 11 kg lors de sa
grossesse
deux kilos mais moi j'aimerais vraiment
compte des complexes les femmes par
rapport à ça on est pas toutes égales on
n'a pas la même morphologie pas la même
génétique on n'est pas égale par rapport
à ça alors oui c'est génial moi j'ai des
copines comme vite à amel bent ou même
nabila qui sont juste après leur
accouchement avait un ventre plat moi ça
n'a pas été mon cas et c'est moi qu'on
des complexes les femmes autour de ça on
est pas toutes égales là tu souffres
kate middleton on l'a vu oui magnifique
we have an après les mêmes techniques
sont encore à elle révélé elle boit
matin midi et sous la fusion d'un
smoothie base de tenez vous bien
spiruline match à épinards myrtille elle
va ou c'est là elles vont faire
[Applaudissements]
tous les lots alors voilà vous m'avez
latière perdure bon je sais que vous
avez vu des images de moi après
ça arrive de temps en temps un
nombre
importe quel monde le mien le vôtre se
tourne temps en temps on en vient peu de
alors attention j'en veux à personne ni
avec ses larges aubergiste personne mais
qu'on arrête de me dire comme je n'ai
entendu dix fois à tf1 ces mômes été
suivi il y avait un psy on apprenait
fois
ci dans secret story tous les mois
jusqu'à la fin une fois que j'ai eu la
victoire j'ai eu une heure avec un psy
mais après c'est vrai qu'une fois qu'on
a fait du plateau rémois après j'ai été
invité dans des fêtes grandioses
incroyable oui j'avais jamais vu ou
croisés de la drogue de ma vie après je
suis arrivé dans des grands appartements
parisiens benoît est ce que tu peux vous
raconter juste un truc parce que tu m'as
pas quand il a gagné benoît elle après
un succès plus de 300 mille balles entre
comme ça en deux cent mille km2 900
milles et c'est ça qui est intéressant
est ton derrière et emmené dans un hôtel
pour que ça se calme tellement iv de
foule est tombé dans une chambre d'hôtel
pendant combien de jours par mois
pendant une semaine j'étais vraiment
sous la responsabilité de tf1 avec des
gardes du corps je n'ai pas le droit de
sortir de l'hôtel j'ai pas loin d'ouvrir
les rideaux avec les photographes en
face ça a duré pendant une semaine genre
appartenait il m'emmenait un peu comme
un produit télévisuel à droite à gauche
et au bout d'une semaine et m'ont dit où
est ce que tu veux qu'on te ramène et
moi je dis bah je sais pas je dis va
ramener mois chez ma mère et mon
descendu donc jusqu'à chez ma mère avec
des photographes tués j'arrive devant
chez ma mère il ya des paparazzi qui
sont devant chez la mère de mon petit
village en bourgogne de la totale et
après leur grosse voiture de production
repart et moi je suis tous les
états unis de nombreux militantes
féministes ont dénoncé le traitement
médiatique et la haine diffusés à
l'encontre d'anders york durant ce
procès alors on a fait appel de sa
condamnation en juin dernier ces
révélations pourraient venir tout
remettre en question et cette fois-ci
l'opinion pourrait bel et bien changé de
côté c'est une avocate en fait qui
s'appelle andrea burkhardt mondiale
influence us parce qu'en fait elle
regardait tout le temps et elle est l
homme l vulgariser un petit peu le
procès sur les réseaux sociaux pour
expliquer aux gens ce qui se passait
tout le temps ce qui est avocate et en
fait elle a décidé de faire en fait de
racheter des dossiers qui n'avaient pas
été traités pendant le procès parce
qu'elles seront ce qu'elles appellent
des vices de forme nocturnes sont des
pièces qu'on ne peut pas utiliser au
procès elle a donné beaucoup d'argent en
fait elle a touché de l'argent via des
fonds parce qu'elle a fait un appel de
fonds est alors pris toutes ces pièces
qui n'avaient pas été sortis pendant le
procès et elle s'est rendu compte
qu'avec toutes ces pièces si en fait
peut-être y avait pas eu toutes ces
magouilles de vice de forme johnny depp
aurait peut-être perdu parce qu'ils
avaient des pièces qui sembleraient
prouvé qu'en réalité il a vraiment été
violent et qui voulait la frapper
les deux grandes stars comme ça un peu
comme back home de chacun avant tout à
chacun chez le coiffeur qu'elle se
confie un peu ce moment elle parle elle
vous raconte des choses et le quota
peut-être là médicale ouais bien sûr et
c'est le moment où elle sera une fille
c'est aussi parfois un elle se confie
pas où elles restent aussi dans le
silence et le besoin elles ont besoin
aussi de de ce justement de se relâcher
avant 2 avant de c'est pas moi par
exemple de franchir le tapis rouge
compressée ça parce que c'est donc c'est
aussi un pur elle aussi un moment de
détente non mais comme dalé chiante
allait compliquer l exigeante à
l'exubérante mal c'est comme ça qu'on
dit
dans le métier ils exigent beaucoup mais
c'est vrai que je lis des mois j'ai déjà
coiffé ça s'est toujours très bien passé
avec elle je les coiffes et quelquefois
mais par contre j'ai vu parfois
effectivement d insupportable et des
maquilleuses avec qui ça s'est pas très
bien passé avait accord un plan pas un
plan perruque pas perdu comme août pas
moumoute faucheux faut toujours aller
aussi raju parages où m alors voilà
c'est ya du coup et
a priori elle parfois elle utilise des
perruques
dit elle le dit
des perruques monica bellucci mais des
perruques m'a
énormément de femmes qui rajoute enfin
des petites bandes derrière c'est
naturel moi j'ai rien du tout ouais
c'est naturellement
mais c'est vrai qu'après qu'ils le font
et ça ça donne plus de glamour alors la
suivante regarde
non mais beaucoup de gens mais il a
parlé la veille le chou qui partait dans
tous les sens et beaucoup toi qui dit il
a un petit loupé un truc non non c'est
une rumeur mais je pense qu'il va rien
il a rien du tout
de macron jeunes mais notez le chemin
plantations il perd un petit peu les
golfs ici à
bruxelles en mai pour face matt pokora
peux me passer matt pokora ah bin là il
ya un plan là y'a quoi matt pokora y
avait un plan il ya un plan vous avez vu
brel allions dire un playmobil à l'eau
évidemment en effet ce qu'on appelle
déjà
apparaître comme un spécialiste mais le
côté chambre poireau quoi le côté toc
toc toc toc
lui un godet chambord au bacon motta
photos de donald trump à vous souvenez
qu'il avait fait une émission de
télévision en deuxième partie de soirée
on l'est il avait dit à l'animateur
tirer mon lait chaud ou vrs c'est pas
une moumoute parce qu'il avait été élu
voilà
exceptionnel mais c'est vrai je pense
qu'il n'avait pas ne l avait pas de mon
moteur c'est vrai échange un vrai et il
devait certainement ramener les cheveux
les faire un brushing et kiev est un peu
passé tu es d'accord j'avais forcément
un coiffeur un autre histoire